How's it going everyone? This is going
to be a more advanced video tailored to
those of you that trade Forex. We are
going to be talking about pairing
currencies using futures, but we will
also talk about futures currencies as
well. So, let's get into the PDF. The
first thing we are going to have to
understand is fractions. Yes, we are
going back to math class. We are always
going to start at 1/1 = 1 and then we'll
get into the various scenarios. Now,
these icons over here on the right, this
is what they mean. If we have a gray
line, that is no trend, with a bullish
trend, bearish trend, strong bullish
trend, strong bearish trend. So, we're
always going to start with this number
here.
If we go to this first example, if we
are raising the denominator, well, then
we are going to lower the number. So,
what does that look like with a
currency? Right? If we are keeping the
currency on top the same, but we are
pairing that with a strong currency,
well, then what we are left with is a
currency that is bearish. Now, if we
lower the numerator, we end up with the
same scenario because we are just
lowering the numerator, which gives us a
bearish currency. Now, how do we take
that one step further? Well, we are
going to do something on both sides of
the fraction. If we lower the numerator
while raising the denominator, well,
then we're getting a very strong bearish
trend. Right? So, pairing a weak
currency with a strong currency gives
you a very weak currency.
And if you can see here, this is
something you want to avoid, raising
both the numerator and the denominator
or lowering both the numerator and the
denominator as price is not going to
change or the trend will not change.
This example down here, if we just raise
the numerator, well, you're taking a
bullish trend, pairing it against
something that is not moving, you're
just going to be left with a bullish
trend.
Right here, if we pair a consolidation
with something that is bearish, well,
then you're going to have something that
is bullish.
And then this is the one we want to
focus on where if we raise the
numerator, lower the denominator, we're
going to get a very bullish trend. So,
it's pairing something that is bullish
with something that is bearish, you get
a very bullish trend. So, let's go over
this in a more organized fashion.
Starting with what we want to avoid. We
want to avoid pairing a weak currency
with a weak currency or a strong
currency with a strong currency as you
will end up with a currency that is not
trending, it is consolidating because
they are moving in the same direction.
Now, it is okay, but not the best to
pair something with a consolidation. So,
you can see here, if you're pairing
something that is weak or strong with a
consolidation, you will have a trend,
but it won't be a super strong trend.
Now, what we want to focus on is finding
the weakest currency and pairing that
with the strongest currency. So, here
you can see we have a weak currency.
We pair that with a strong currency and
we end up with a very weak currency.
Now, we can also do that by pairing a
strong currency with a weak currency and
ending up with a very strong currency.
So, now that you understand the fraction
side of things, the math behind it,
let's go over some examples here. We are
first going to focus on when the dollar
is trending or DXY. If the dollar is
trending, I just want to focus on
pairing stuff with the dollar. So, here
you can see the dollar is in a strong
bullish trend. So, what would we want to
pair it with? Would we want to pair it
with something that is also trending?
No, because then we're going to be left
with a currency that is consolidating.
We want to look for a currency that is
weak. So, if we come over here, the
dollar is trending, euro is very
bearish. Right? Here are our bearish
currencies, but euro is the most
bearish. So, if we want the best
expansion out of a currency, we want to
pair the strongest and the weakest one
together. So, pairing the dollar with
the euro or euro with the dollar will
give a strong bearish trend or we are
left with trading EUR/USD.
The next example is if dollar is
trending lower. We would want to then
pair it with something that is bullish.
So, taking a look over here, do we have
a strong bullish currency? And here we
do as we have the yen that is very
bullish. So, we can pair the dollar with
the yen and we get left with a very
strong bearish trend. And as because we
are pairing the dollar with JPY, we
trade USD/JPY.
So, simply put, these are the rules and
this is what you will want to
screenshot. If the dollar is trending,
you want to pair it with something. If
the dollar is bullish, find the weakest
currency to pair with it. If the dollar
is bearish, find the strongest currency
to pair with it. Now, let's say the
dollar is in a consolidation. That is
where it gets a bit more advanced. We
are not going to pair with the dollar,
but we're going to pair with another
currency. And this is what we want to
focus on. We want to pair that strong
currency with a weak currency or a weak
currency with a strong currency. Now,
there will be times where we have all
the currencies trending up and we don't
have something that is bearish. That is
when we can pair it with something
that's consolidating and we'll still get
a trend. Let's take a look at these
exotic examples. So, since the dollar is
consolidating, we want to look for a
bullish currency and a bearish currency.
So, taking a look, euro is very strong,
yen is very weak. So, those are the two
we would pair together. So, we would
pair the euro, which is bullish, with
the yen, which is bearish. What do we
end up with? A strong bullish trend. So,
taking a look at another example here,
the dollar is consolidating, so we want
to find a bearish and a bullish
currency. The pound and the New Zealand
dollar. By pairing those together, we
get a strong bearish trend. Now, what do
you do if you just trade futures and you
don't trade Forex? Well, if the dollar
is trending, it's very simple. You're
just going to find the one opposite that
is the strongest or weakest. So, if the
dollar is bullish, you want to find the
most bearish currency future and that is
what you will be trading.
If the dollar is bearish, you want to
find the strongest currency future and
that is what you will be trading.
Now, what do we do if dollar is
consolidating? We have two options. We
can once again just find the one that is
trending the most and trade it or if we
want to have a similar framework to the
exotic pairs, we can trade them both in
opposite directions. Let's say the
dollar is trending. We have a bearish
trend in pound and NZD has a bullish
trend, well, then we could long one and
short one and that's very similar to
just trading GBP/NZD.
So, I know this can be confusing, it'll
just take a bit of practice to
understand. Let's go into TradingView
and we can go over a few examples of
pairing some currencies together. So,
here we are in our first example and
we're taking a look here at dollar and
the dollar is trending downwards, right?
We have a nice bearish engulfing monthly
candle. We respect the lower half of
that and we're trading a continuation
lower. We could look for this to
continue lower.
Now, if we are bearish on dollar, what
do we want to find? We want to find a
bullish foreign currency. So, let's take
a look here. Euro, that is bullish.
Pound, you see how that is not as
bullish as euro. So, so far, we could
look at EUR/USD. We would want to avoid
GBP/USD.
Now, taking a look at yen, that is quite
bullish, we could look at that. CAD, we
would want to avoid that, right? Cuz
it's also bearish.
Swissy, we could look at that, it's
pretty strong, but it has just taken out
a pretty big target. And NZD/AUD also
bearish. So, by taking a look at this,
which ones do we want to focus on? Well,
we could focus on JPY or euro. So, then
we could look at EUR/USD for the next
day or USD/JPY for the next day.
So, let's take a look, let this play
ahead and what do we get?
USD/JPY gives an expansion lower,
EUR/USD gives an expansion higher. So,
that is how you can pair those together.
First, you want to take a look at the
dollar and get a bias. So, in this case,
it's bearish, then you want to pair it
with foreign currencies that you have
the other direction anticipated. Now, if
you go ahead and take a look, we had
pound not really doing much. So, we take
a look at GBP/USD, it's not really going
to have an expansion day like EUR/USD
does. So, that's why it's important to
consider the futures and pairing those
currencies together to make sure you
align yourself for expansion. So, here
we are in another example and I want to
say there's not always going to be just
one best currency to trade. A lot of
times there are multiple different
options for a single day, but there are
certainly ones that you want to avoid.
So, taking a look at this, what do we
have? We have a candle to closure here
on the dollar
and then we have equal lows below. If
you want to check out this trade review,
it is on my channel. I ended up trading
CAD futures, but we have a candle to
closure to trade lower. So, I want to
look for a bullish foreign currency. So,
taking a look, is euro set up for
expansion? Yeah, it has a nice bullish
candle, but it's not super great in my
eyes. Does pound? Yeah, pound has a nice
candle to closure right here. So, euro
or pound, you know, you could both trade
those. JPY, well, we're wanting to see a
bullish asset, right? This is quite
bearish. So, I'm going to want to avoid
JPY. So, I wouldn't want to trade
USD/JPY.
Now, CAD, what do we have? We have a
nice closure and a nice fair value gap
here and then a ideal candle to closure.
And this is why I took it because it
looked the best to me on this time
frame. Now, let's go take a look at
Swissy. Right? Not that great. NZD and
AUD are also both strong. So, taking a
look at this, because we have a bearish
dollar, we could really pair this
against anything, but I would want to
avoid JPY or the Swissy as there is not
relative strength in those markets. So,
taking a look, let's see how this plays
out. If we take a look at anything other
than those two assets, you can see we
get a nice expansion here on Euro. GBP
has a nice expansion as well. And you
can see JPY doesn't really do much and
that's because you're pairing a weak
currency as we can let this play out
with a weak future, right? You want to
pair it with a strong future. So, USD
JPY doesn't really get much of a move.
While you look at CAD, it does okay.
CHF does okay. NZD and AUD do really
well. So, this is just an example
showing when you have a dollar bias,
it's not always going to be perfect.
You're not going to have one asset
that's just, "Hey, this is the strongest
asset." There are a lot of times
multiple different choices. For
instance, you could have traded this on
Euro. You could have traded this on
pound. You could have traded on CAD. You
could have done NZD or AUD. Really, any
of those works. But, really what you
want to do is really focus or hone in on
the ones you don't want to trade. If
you're trying to trade that day on JPY,
you're not really going to get much
movement because it is not that bullish
relative to the other currencies. So,
here we are in our next example and in
this example, we're going to go over
exotic pairing or pairing with things
that are not the dollar. Now, just to
review the dollar, when the dollar is
trending, just focus on the currency
futures that are opposing it. So, here
if the dollar is trending lower, you
want to find the bullish futures
currencies and then pair those together
or trade those if you trade futures.
Now, if the dollar is not trending or
consolidating, let's talk about what to
do there. Now, when can you anticipate
consolidation? Generally, after a large
expansion or hitting a higher time frame
key level. Here we have both and this is
what I was talking about on Twitter. So,
we have dollar reaching into a important
level after expanding. What can you
anticipate for the dollar? Either a new
phase of price, so either retracement,
reversal, or a consolidation. I'm
personally anticipating consolidation or
retracement on the dollar. So, I would
want to look towards foreign currencies
and pair those together. Now, if the
dollar is retracing or consolidating,
that means Euro or pound are going to be
doing what? Doing the same but in the
other direction. So, if we can
anticipate Euro or pound to go lower,
right? Then we can pair something with
that. Let's give it one more day to give
a little bit more context. So, we let
that new day print and you can see we
are getting a consolidation or retracing
back into the range. So, generally
speaking, that makes Euro or pound
bearish. So, you can see we have bearish
Euro and pound also bearish. Now,
looking at these candle closures
together, what do we see? Well, I see
that Euro is more bearish. So, that
generally makes me want to focus on
Euro.
So, if I'm looking at Euro, I want to
pair it with something that is what?
Bullish because I want to do opposites.
If I'm looking at a bearish currency, I
want to find a bullish currency. So,
then I look. Bullish? No.
Bullish? No.
Oh, I found a bullish currency. So, now
instead of pairing with a dollar, I
found a currency that is bearish and I
found a currency that is bullish. So,
Euro and CAD. We can take a look at the
other ones to see if I'm missing
anything.
We could do NZD or AUD. So, really I
want to do Euro against the CAD or Euro
against the New Zealand dollar or the
Australian dollar. So, let's take a look
at that. Euro CAD. Pull that up.
You can see we got an expansion off of a
high,
a reversal, and then we're trading
towards a low. So, you could be trading
this day lower.
Right? Let's take a look at something
like Euro versus NZD.
And same thing, we're getting an
expansion lower. Let's take a look at
Euro AUD.
And once again, not as good of an
expansion but an expansion lower. Now,
if we try to pair stuff against the
dollar or look at Euro USD, you see how
we're just stuck in a consolidation.
So, that's why when the dollar is
consolidating, I can focus on pairing
futures currencies together to find the
Forex pair that I want to trade. I'm
going to do that by finding one asset
that is going in the opposite direction
or the other or a very trending asset
with one that is opposing it or
consolidating. So, I did that by looking
at Euro and then finding stuff that was
strong, which ended up with giving me
Euro CAD. And that also had a nice daily
framework as we ran out these highs and
then we could trade through these lows.
Now, I don't want this video to get too
long. I know it is a lot of information
and can be quite confusing, but it's
just going to take some practice, right?
You have to understand how fractions
work and then really simply, you want to
pair things that are going in the
opposite direction and that's how you're
going to find expansions within the
Forex currency market. If you did enjoy
this video, please give it a like and
subscribe and I'll see you guys next
time. Have a good one.